take you out of that report from into
man Rasheed let's go live to the old
bayley where former U.S spy and tsukulis
is being sentenced by Mrs Justice G
McGraw 2019.
you drove out of the military base at
Raf croughton
and turned left onto the b4031
towards croughton Village
it was about 8 20 in the evening there
was good visibility
two of your own children were in the
back of your car
when you turned
you immediately went onto the wrong side
of the road
where you traveled for about
350 meters
just less than 30 seconds later your car
hit the motorcycle being ridden by Harry
Dunn who was just 19 years old
he had spent the 27th of August 2019
with his best friend
he was happy he loved motorbikes
there is no suggestion that he was
driving anything other than entirely
properly
he was on the right side of the road
driving perfectly normally
excessive speed was not involved
on either side
at the point of the Collision there was
a slight Bend and rise in the road
the impact with the front of your car
through him onto the front of your car
and then over the top of it until he
landed in the road
his bike caught fire and was pushed
backwards
another driver arrived soon afterwards
and called the Emergency Services
you got out realized what had happened
and were very distressed
you spoke to Mr Dunn who was conscious
and speaking you got your children out
of the car and called your husband and
the RAF base
you confirmed to the police
that what happened was your fault and
you had been on the wrong side of the
road
a breath test was administered and was
negative
you said you had made a mistake
Mr Dunn suffered multiple severe
injuries
he was very Gravely ill when he was
taken to hospital and he died soon
afterwards
you were not arrested at the time you
did not remain in the United Kingdom you
left on the 15th of September 2019
you submitted to a voluntary interview
with the police in Washington D.C on the
28th of October
as you had at the roadside you admitted
you were responsible
a request for your extradition was
submitted in 2020
it was denied
immunity from Criminal prosecution was
claimed for you by the government of the
United States of America and accepted by
the British government
as the high court of justice in London
found in its judgment on the challenge
of Mr Dunn's parents to that decision
in in the crown on the application of
Charlotte Charles and Tim Dunn against
the Secretary of State for the foreign
and Commonwealth Affairs and the chief
Constable of northamptonshire police
2020
ewhc 3185 admin you did indeed enjoy
that immunity at the time of the
accident which killed their son
there is no doubt that the calm and
dignified Persistence of these parents
and the family of that young man
has led through three years of
heartbreak and effort to your appearance
before the court and the opportunity for
you to acknowledge acknowledge your
guilt of a crime
eventually you are charged with death by
dangerous driving by written requisition
pursuant to section 3 of the crime
International cooperation Act 2003.
changes in the law brought by part 8 of
the criminal justice act 2003
by the police crime sentencing and
courts act 2022 guaranteed powers or
rather granted powers to the criminal
courts to permit a person to take part
in criminal proceedings through a live
link
the chief magistrate granted a live link
order and you appeared before
Westminster magistrates court on the
29th of September 2022
your case was sent to the central
Criminal Court
by participating in video link
proceedings at Westminster magistrates
you surrendered to the court
when your case was sent for trial to
this court you were given unconditional
bail
surrender to this court was accomplished
when you were identified as being
present Again by video link on the 20th
of October 2022
you were arraigned and you pleaded
guilty to a lesser offense that of
causing death by careless or
inconsiderate driving contrary to
section 2B of the Road Traffic Act 1988.
the court granted a live link for your
arraignment because in my judgment it
was in the public interest for you to be
able to enter your plea and it would not
defeat the interests of Justice if that
was accomplished by you participating
through a live link
at no point in these proceedings had it
been suggested that you were not free
and able to travel to this jurisdiction
in person
once you had pleaded guilty and were
therefore a convicted offender there
could be little reason in a case where a
young man had met his death for you not
to be required to attend at court for
sentence
your bail was not withdrawn and you were
released from the court but directed to
attend in person for this sentencing
hearing
I directed you to attend and observed
that attendance in person would be
strong evidence of remorse
for the purpose of section 6-1 of the
bay light 1976 you had a duty to
surrender to the court
failure of a defendant in a criminal
trial to attend in person when directed
to do so without reasonable cause is an
offense contrary to the bail Act
it has the potential to affect the
Court's ability to administer Justice by
damaging the confidence of victims
Witnesses and the public more generally
in the effectiveness of the court system
judges have to consider taking
appropriate action if there is no
sufficient justification for a failure
to attend
the usual action is to issue a bench
warrant not backed for bail which will
result in the arrest of the defendant
when they are located
your sentence is due to take place on
the 1st of December a week before that
date on the 24th of November the court
received a renewal of the application
for you to appear by live link
this included references to harassment
and threats you and your family had
received mainly by social media and many
emanating from the United States of
America
and an assessment that this gave rise to
a risk to your personal safety if you
travel to the United Kingdom
it did not include any reference to a
barrier imposed by the government
authorities to your traveling to London
to face sentence in person
as a consequence of what the court
received I asked the prosecution to
provide a response to the material
submitted
very swiftly by the 28th of November the
northamptonshire police
compiled an operation
which set out in detail four Plans by
means of which your safety could be
protected if you were to return to the
jurisdiction to be sentenced
accordingly I maintained my order that
the hearing be in person
however a request was made on your
behalf for a delay of a week to obtain
further Evidence
this was allowed
on Friday the 2nd of December a
statement was served from Amy Jeffries
your attorney who accompanies you today
and I granted the application on Monday
the 5th of December
the reasons were that for the first time
in these criminal proceedings a barrier
to your attendance emanating from the
American government was relied on in
support of the application
in her statement Miss Jeffrey says quote
the U.S government does not in any way
support mississ
appearing in person at this hearing in
fact Mrs sakulis's U.S government
employer has advised her not to return
to the United Kingdom in person for this
hearing because her return could play
significant U.S interests at risk this
advice was communicated to her by her
employer on the 30th of November and she
is not at Liberty to disclose the
communication itself or any further
information to the court
by section 51 subsection 3 of the
criminal justice act 2003 as amended by
section 200 of the pcsca 2022 a
sentencing hearing Falls within the list
of eligible criminal proceedings for
which the court has the power to make a
direction pursuant to section 51
subsection 1.
and that power may be exercised in
respect of a person who is outside the
jurisdiction of England and Wales
but the power is subject to section 51
subsection 4A which requires that the
court is satisfied amongst other things
that it is in the interests of Justice
to make the direction
the interests of Justice in a criminal
case are frequently different to the
interests of the defendant
respect for the law must be genuine and
effective substantial and real
the Lord chief justice has provided the
courts with guidance which must be
considered alongside all the
circumstances of the case and particular
factors which are set out in section 51
subsection 6 of the cja
one of those factors is the need for the
defendant to attend in person
paragraph 9 of the guidance issued by
the Lord chief justice invites attention
to such factors as the potential penalty
to be imposed and in paragraph 18
whether a live link would risk damaging
international relations so as to be
contrary to the interests of Justice
when sentences to be imposed for an
offense that involves the fatality there
must be a strong public interest in the
offender being before the court in
person
in other words a need for the defendant
to attend in person
as will become apparent I concluded
provisionally and subject to hearing the
submissions in mitigation today that the
barrier presented by your adherence to
the advice given to you by your
government employer was relevant to my
decision on the use of a live link and
it would not interfere with the due
administration of justice given the
sentence I was likely to impose
the Alternatives would have been to
withdraw your bail if you had not
attended today the result would have
been a warrant for your arrest which
would have been extant until executed or
withdrawn
the issuing of a warrant for your arrest
would have been close to an empty
gesture and it would stall progress in
this case
another option open to the court would
have been to conduct a sentence in your
absence as you are represented by
Council and the court has material upon
which to proceed
it would have been perverse to review to
refuse this video link in these
circumstances and on the 5th of December
I granted the application which remained
a joint one by the defense and the
prosecution
in an eloquent impact statement
Charlotte Charles Harry Dunn's mother
has expressed her sorrow at not being
able to comfort her son as he lay on the
side of the road or in hospital
she is full of regrets
her other son Harry's not twin Niall
feels emptiness
the Deep suffering of the entire family
at the unusual course of events I have
outlined has generated the persistence
that she and her and Harry's father have
shown
she wants Justice for her son
as she promised him
although they've been left with a gaping
hole the family is determined to provide
a legacy for him in projects to help
others
who are you and sakulas
you are a citizen of the United States
of America
you are 45 years old and happily married
with three children of your own age 7 9
and 14 years
you accompanied your husband on his
posting to RAF croughton having arrived
a few weeks before the accident
you had been socializing on the base on
the 27th of August with your husband and
children
he left the base shortly before you and
according to the material before me you
decided to drive home the way he did
even though you are less familiar with
it than another route that you knew
you have expressed your condolences to
Mr Dunn's family through a statement
read by Council on your behalf at this
hearing
causing death by careless or
inconsiderate driving contrary to
section 2B of the Road Traffic Act 1988
can be committed in various ways
sometimes a moment's inattention can
lead to tragic results
this is not such a case
you drove along the wrong side of the
road for much more than a moment
and you did not realize what you were
doing even when you were coming to A
bend in the road when all drivers on a
narrow carriageway would naturally check
that they were driving safely
it seems to me that your conduct albeit
careless rather than deliberate Falls at
The Other Extreme
taking everything into account your
behavior on this occasion was not far
short of deliberately dangerous driving
which results in a death
I bear in mind that this was a short
period of driving and you were not
familiar with English roads
the sentencing Council guideline places
the starting point for sentence for your
offense at 15 months custody
the range it provides is nine months to
three years custody
the death of Harry Dunn is of course the
highest degree of harm
but that is inherent in the charge and
the starting point of 15 months
there are none of the aggravating
features that may appear in some such
cases for example you are not driving
uninsured
there is mitigation in your case
in particular
you are not compelled to submit yourself
to this charge and these proceedings but
have chosen to do so
you had only limited experience of
driving in this country
you offered assistance to Mr Dunn at the
scene and you have never personally
denied responsibility for his death
other features such as the short time
you drove before the Collision also
alleviate the gravity to a degree
you are to be treated as of good
character apart from two minor driving
matters in 1997 and 2006 both of which
resulted in fines
anyone who has caused death by driving
would be expected to feel remorseful
but remorse is important for sentencing
purposes and I accept that you felt and
feel genuine remorse
these features require a reduction in
the starting point and I allow three
months
you indicated a guilty plea to this
offense in the magistrates court and you
entered your guilty plea at the first
opportunity in the Crown Court the law
requires a one-third discount to
recognize this
the shortest term of imprisonment
commensurate with the seriousness of the
offense is therefore eight months
imprisonment
it follows that the offense is so
serious that neither a fine alone nor a
community sentence can be justified for
it
imprisonment must always be the last
resort
your offense passes the custody
threshold as I have indicated but before
deciding that no alternative is
appropriate I have considered whether
that can be avoided
I ordered a pre-sentence report at the
last hearing you will have seen that
report the author has provided me with a
great deal of useful information about
you and she has consulted senior
officers and officials at his Majesty's
prison and probation service
however the author concludes with no
recommendation to the court and state
that her inquiries do not reveal any
practical way in which a form of
community sentence or any other
non-custodial disposal imposed by this
court could be managed in the United
States of America
it is obvious that no enforcement can be
carried out
and no breach of an order could be
prosecuted effectively while you
remained abroad
equally no restorative justice process
can take place except in person
I'm grateful to the probation service
for the inquiries they've made
Counsel on your behalf has submitted
that sentence should be deferred and
that you would arrange to do some form
of voluntary work in recompense
I do not consider that there is any
purpose in deferring sentence
as the pre-sentence report makes clear
you are not someone who needs
Rehabilitation you need to be sentenced
and then both you and the family of
Harry Dunn can move on
if I were to impose an immediate
custodial sentence then you would be
unlawfully at large thereafter and I
would order you to return to the United
Kingdom to serve it the sentence will be
put into effect if and when you enter
the jurisdiction and surrendered to a
police station
before doing so I have considered
whether it is possible to suspend the
sentence
you have the strong personal mitigation
I have already summarized
you are also a mother of young children
who would suffer disproportionate harm
from your immediate imprisonment and I
am satisfied that appropriate punishment
can be achieved without immediate
custody
please stand up Mrs sekulas
you are disqualified from driving for 12
months
for the offense of causing the death of
Harry Dunn by your careless driving the
sentence is eight months imprisonment
suspended for 12 months
there will be no additional requirements
the sentence means that if in the next
12 months you commit any offense
whether or not it is of the same type
for which I'm sentencing you today you
would find yourself before the court
again
and it is likely that the sentence will
be brought into operation either in full
or in part
thank you very much you may sit down
that was of course Mrs Justice Chima
grub but passing her sentence uh on Ann
sakulis uh the bottom line there which
we reached at the end was uh that uh
Miss cesculus will be disqualified from
driving uh for 12 months and received an
eight-month prison sentence suspended uh
for 12 months and those final moments
there from Mrs Justice sir Chima grub
but explained why she felt uh the prison
sentence of eight months though
warranted uh needed to be suspended and
just all arguments of practicality uh
meant it needed to be suspended because
she could not submit herself to prison
in the UK uh immediately a sort of way
out perhaps you could frame that of all
the complications of this particular
case let's get to immediate reaction
from someone who knows this case
incredibly well Sky crossed into Lisa
dad is outside of old bayley and uh
there was a prison sentence there Lisa
albeit suspended past there by Mrs
Justice chimograph
yes during that sentencing Mrs Justice
Chima Grubb took us through the details
of that night and the aggravating
factors particularly that Mrs seculars
had been on the wrong side of the road
for quite a long time up to 26 seconds
before she hit Harry Dunn but what Mrs
Chima Grubb pointed out was that there
were no aggravating factors she hadn't
been drinking alcohol she hadn't been
speeding and she took into account
mitigation that Mrs sakulas had
voluntarily taken part in these
proceedings that she'd offered
assistance to Harry Dunn as he Lay Dying
at the scene that she freely admitted
her part in his death and that she was
of good character except for two minor
driving us fences in the U.S a number of
years ago and the the judge accepted
that Mrs sakulas did feel a genuine
remorse for what had happened so a
passing sentence she sentenced she asked
Mrs sakulas who was on video link from
Washington to stand up and she told her
that she was disqualified from driving
for 12 months and that she would have an
eight-month suspended prison sentence
and if she was to commit any further
offense in the next 12 months that she
would be bought before the court again
of course all of this has been voluntary
for Mrs circula so if anything further
was to happen it would be up to her
whether she took part in any further
proceedings now we await the reaction
from Harry Dunn's family who have been
in court listening to that intently they
have always said they didn't
particularly expect any kind of
custodial sentence they just wanted to
see Mr circus face Justice in a UK Court
they have been happy for this to happen
remotely but they would have preferred
that she had come for sentencing back to
the United Kingdom and the judge took us
through some of the detail in the run-up
to this court hearing and she felt there
was little reason for Mrs sakulas not to
return to the UK to the Old Bailey today
she had directed to her to attend we
heard a bit of background detail some of
the legal wranglings going on in the
background with regards to her
attendance Mr circulas and her lawyers
had claimed that she had been harassed
on social media she didn't feel safe
coming back to the UK and at one point
there was no reference to the United
States government her employer being a
barrier to her coming back
point that changed a couple of days ago
and her lawyers said that the U.S
government did not want her to return in
person
um because it would Place significant
U.S interests at risk so she is a via
video link from the United States and
Harry Dunn's family are in court they'll
be coming out to give their reaction
shortly and Lisa we of course await that
reaction it is a moment that might
provide them some closure or albeit of
course we heard Also earlier from the
victim impact statements that she'll
never be able to really get over this
from Harry Dunn's mother
I think they found some closure from the
very first time that they saw Mrs
takulas in court and they are happy to
see her in court via video link again
but as I've said they would have
preferred to see her here in person and
they have perhaps been filled in a
little bit more about the background to
what happened to Harry that night we
heard in court that the whole collision
had been caught on air base cameras at
Raf Croton in northamptonshire back in
August 2019 that Mr sakulas had driven
out of the air base Mrs Chima Grubb the
judge had been describing how the
sakulas family had been socializing at
the air base that they had left the air
base in separate cars Mrs sekulas
following her husband who left the base
and she though pulled onto the wrong
side of the road she was on the wrong
side of the road for up to 26 seconds
when she was in collision with Harry
Dunn she was on the wrong side of the
road he was on the correct side of the
road on a motorbike and the footage
captured the moment where they collided
there was an explosion there was a fire
Harry was thrown from his motorbike over
her vehicle a Volvo onto the road and we
heard some awful testimony from a
witness who was first at the scene she'd
found mississ who had her children in
the car at the time at the side of the
road and Mrs sakulas told the witness
I've had a head-on collision with a
motorbike it's all my fault I was on the
wrong side of the road I've only been
here a few weeks referring to the fact
that she'd only recently come to the UK
and she wasn't familiar with UK roads
and the witness also said how Harry was
lying on the road with multiple injuries
and he said to her don't let me die
we heard that Mrs sakulas had cooperated
with police in the UK had given
interviews and it had not been her
decision to claim diplomatic immunity
and leave the country
after the crash that that was taken on
her behalf by her employer the United
States government we heard in a defense
that she had not been speeding she had
not been drinking she pleaded guilty at
the earliest opportunity but she said
since the crash she had been the subject
of harassment death threats she's had to
move house and she's been diagnosed with
a stress related disorder and her
lawyers made the point on her behalf
that not a day went by where Harry was
not on her mind and she wiped away a
tear as she heard testimony in court for
from Charlotte Charles Harry's mother
who read out Victim Impact statements
and the impact his death had had on her
and her wider family over the years
while they've been trying to get Justice
for him Charlotte Charles referred to
Harry as the light of her life and she
said it still haunted her that she
hadn't got to hospital in time to be
with him before he died and she felt
that she'd lost two sons that night
because Harry we should remember was a
twin and his twin brother Niall has also
been suffering terribly with the loss of
Harry
Mrs Charles said we don't live anymore
we simply just function and at that
point Mr kulas on the video link from
Washington wiped away at here
doubt uh thanks so much for that let's
get further analysis now Joshua
Rosenberg uh joins us as well and Josh
your first your your reaction to the
sentence uh itself uh a custodial
sentence uh suspended though and
therefore unlikely ever to actually be
served
correct unless uh answer kulis were to
commit other offenses in the next 12
months unless of course she would return
to the United Kingdom then she won't
have to serve that sentence that's what
a suspended sentence is I think the
sentence was straight down the line once
it was accepted that this was at the top
end of the offense this was careless or
inconsiderate driving falling not far
short of dangerous driving well the
starting point for that in the
guidelines which the judges must follow
the starting point for that is 15 months
custody there were mitigating
circumstances which allowed the judge to
reduce that to 12 months custody in
other words three months off the
starting point
then because she pleaded guilty at the
first opportunity it was reduced by a
third to eight months and that was
obviously when answer coolers must have
wondered whether the judge was actually
going to impose a sentence of immediate
custody but she decided that she could
suspend the sentence which is the same
means that in in practice it won't have
to be served I think one of the very
interesting legal aspects to emerge from
what Mrs Justice Gina Grubb said to
answer kulis just now
is the arrangements with the United
States at the previous hearing the judge
said you must come back to London for
the sentencing I can't see any reason
why you should not and then we heard
that the lawyers asked for another
remote hearing saying that they didn't
want her to come back and the judge said
well why and then the lawyers asked for
more time and then we had this very
interesting uh uh message from the US
government that she had been advised not
to return because this could put U.S
interests at risk
and I think this is a hint at what lies
behind this case you've been describing
answer hoolis as a spy we don't know
exactly what she does we don't know
exactly what a husband does but there is
no doubt they work for the US government
there is no doubt that the base where
they worked was a Communications station
and there was no doubt that they were
involved in secret work and and that was
why they were allowed diplomatic
Privileges and what the US government
was saying was that if she came back to
the UK that would jeopardize the U.S
national security and they weren't
prepared to explain in what way and that
seems to have influenced the judge to
allow today's hearing to take place
remotely the judge made it clear that if
it wasn't for that then uh anzaculus
would have been in breach of her bail
conditions she would have failed to
surrender to her bail as the judge had
ordered and that would have increased
her sentence so the fact that the US
government belatedly told the UK through
anseculus's lawyers that it was
important to the U.S for answer coolers
not to return clearly had an influence
on the judge's decision to pass a
suspended sentence as of course did the
fact that it's not possible we heard for
any sin there's not even a community
sentence to be carried out in the United
States so really the judge was left with
no alternative but she marked the
gravity of this case by saying that this
was a case that would normally be
visited with eight months imprisonment
and well on that note Joshua is it your
interpretation of the facts but but also
what we just heard from the judge that
had musculus been able to be present the
sentence would not have been suspended
if she had returned uh that would have
demonstrated remorse which is something
that the judge said she would take into
account
so I think if she had returned it would
have been better for her than it is at
the moment or at least no worse
I think if she had returned then she
would still have received a suspended
sentence now the judge made inquiries
and the police were able to work out
various ways in which answer coolers
could have been returned to the United
Kingdom at no risk to herself presumably
brought by a police car through the back
entrance of the Old Bailey or something
like that and then assuming no custodial
sentence was passed whisked away and
returned to the United States but we can
see that the U.S government wasn't
prepared to take that risk because of
what it said would be damage to U.S
interests would put U.S interests at
risk and perhaps the U.S government
was wise to take that approach because
as the judge said this could have been
an immediate custodial sentence
and circulars would have been in prison
people would have tried to get
information out of her who knows what
the risk would have been to the U.S so
you can perhaps understand why the U.S
took a very firm line on this but no I
think if she had returned to the United
Kingdom she might well have received a
suspended sentence
um in the same way as she actually did
and just finally and quickly Josh I'm
interested the fact that she came from
the U.S and her license was issued by
the U.S and therefore was used to
driving on the other side of the road
that that is a mitigating Factor could
could one not in layman terms from which
I come uh come from assume quite the
opposite that if you choose to drive in
a foreign country and the license you
are doing to do so with your full
knowledge comes from different dimension
you are responsible for for the
different laws that might apply
you are certainly responsible and I
think the Judge made that very clear the
judge made it clear that she should have
been more cautious as she approached the
the brow of the Hill the bend in the
road but on the other hand you know many
of us have driven um in the U.S and on
the continent if you are on a Motorway
it's no problem at all the traffic's
going One Direction if you come out of a
service station of a private road onto a
main road and there's no traffic going
in either direction and there are just
dotted lines down the middle of the road
I suspect some of us have instinctively
driven on the wrong side of the road uh
just for a moment until we suddenly
realized hang on I'm on the wrong side
and that's clearly what happened here so
I think that the judge was showing some
understanding of this position but
clearly she thought that even um you
know if somebody momentarily sets out on
the wrong side of the road they want to
think hang on
um I'm driving in a foreign country the
rule of the road is different I think it
is a mitigating circumstance but it does
show how terribly important it is to be
aware as a driver and what a dangerous
thing it is to drive a car Joshua thanks
so much for all your expert analysis
throughout the afternoon uh Joshua
Rosenberg there
um this is the statement by the way that
was read out on behalf of Anne sekulis
during the hearing at the Old Bailey she
says quote I want to again extend my
sincerest condolences to Harry Dunn's
family and friends my tragic mistake led
to the loss of Harry and I live with
this regret every single day there's not
a day that goes by that Harry isn't on
my mind and I'm deeply sorry for the
pain that I've caused it's for this
reason that I've been so committed to a
resolution to this case since 2019. I
know there's nothing I can say to change
what has happened I only hope that the
truth and a resolution to this case will
bring a measure of comfort and peace as
always I remain willing to meet and
apologize to Harry's family directly if
that would help if that support their
healing Harry was a young man with his
whole life ahead of him I cannot imagine
the loss and I too deeply grieve that
Harry and his family I'm grateful that I
could express my profound remorse to the
court and to Harry's friends and family
August 27 2019 changed the lives of so
many and I pray for healing I kindly ask
the media for privacy
and the foreign secretary James
cleverley has given his reaction he said
quote answer kulis has finally been
sentenced in a British Court since
Harry's death in August 2019 we've been
cleared that Mr kulis should return to
the UK to face British Justice since she
chose not to Virtual hearings were
arranged and as the most viable way to
bring the case to court and give Justice
to Harry's family I want to pay tributes
to the incredible resolve of Harry's
family and I hope that the Judgment
provides some closure we've learned
important lessons from this tragic
incident including improvements to the
process around exemptions from
diplomatic immunity and ensuring the U.S
takes steps to improve Road Safety
around RAF Croton
joining me now uh from uh the old
bellies Nick vamos partner at Peter and
Peter's solicitors and the former head
of extradition and the crown prosecution
service Who was appointed by the Dunn
family to advise on securing prosecution
for answer curse thanks so much for for
joining me uh I I'm interested in in
first of all your perspective on the
details we learned today on why antacus
was not present in person uh today
initially making a case that it was
based on her own safety and only after a
late intervention by the U.S government
was it possible for her to remain in the
U.S
well I'm sure both were true that she
was concerned for her safety and that
the whole time the US government was
working to prevent her return and they
obviously didn't want to say that
publicly but were forced to when the
judge said that she wouldn't otherwise
exclude her or forgive her attendance so
the US government were always thought to
have been pulling her strings from
behind the scenes and of course they had
to then come out from behind the curtain
and reveal that that was exactly what
they were doing and they said that
significant U.S interests were in play
which is why they had to do that we
don't know what those interests are I
can imagine they want to protect all
their diplomatic staff anywhere in the
world and they have a policy that they
don't want people to go back to a
country to face prosecution it's a shame
they didn't feel they were able to do
that for the UK where we're meant to be
their closest allies but that was their
decision and so the judge really had no
choice but to deal with it this way uh
are you surprised in any way at the
sentence
I'm not surprised that the judge brought
it to an end today if she'd imposed a
custodial sentence but not suspended it
then the questions would have remained
whether Justice had yet been done how
would she ever face that sentence and I
think that would have not helped the
family I think at the Forefront of the
judge's mind was not to cause any more
pain to the family and how to achieve
that while staying within the guidelines
and and doing something that that felt
like justice so I think the sentence was
the right one
um and you know it feels uncomfortable
that we've had to do this remotely from
start to finish that she's avoided
extradition which anybody else would
have faced but I think the sentence is
probably what she would have received
anyway and we are waiting to hear from
Harry's Dunn's family in fact we can
listen to them now
foreign
photography here let's listen though to
Harry John's family um Everybody well
we've just come out of what has to be
one of the most extraordinary uh
legal cases in in English history I mean
it's just absolutely incredible I just
want to um
just again pay tribute to the courage of
the parents we all heard what the judge
said the the calm dignified but
persistent matter in which they've
campaigned for justice for their son I
think is unprecedented and I'm I'm just
in awe of them look in terms of the
sentence it was it was pretty much
everything that we expected uh Mrs
sakulis I think was trying to persuade
the court that that she should be
allowed to do some sort of community
service or scrub toilets clean graffiti
that is not how we do things after the
death of somebody in criminal
circumstances and I want to pay tribute
also to Mrs Justice Chima grub who I
think has done an outstanding job on
behalf of our our legal system and our
country
just finally from me before I hand over
to my son Isaac Seeger who's one of
Harry Dunn's childhood friends and wants
to say a few words as well before we
take questions
look our Real Enemy here is not Mrs
tsukulis we know she made a mistake that
night and and I dare say all of us and
everybody watching at home has made
mistakes on the road but we know she
didn't intend to kill Harry our Real
Enemy here is the US government
who after Harry's death instead of
coming to do the right thing for this
family decided to kick them in the
stomach and continue to kick them in the
stomach for three years
and if it weren't for their friends
their Community you guys in the media
and the Great British and American
public and millions of people around the
world helping us they would have got
away with it well they didn't get away
with it today we all heard the judges
criticisms of the U.S government the
Cowardly approach
to
ensuring that Justice is done here I
think is I think is appalling and I
don't understand why the Americans have
behaved this way
but as Isaac will come on to tell you we
finished this part of the campaign today
but we are absolutely determined to make
sure this never happens to another
British family again thank you Isaac so
thank you for being here I am I grew up
with Harry and Nile through Nursery
secondary and Primary School
Harry was a great person he was very
caring and was taken too soon driving
perfectly safely on the right side of
the road
the way that the U.S government is
treated with this family with uttered
disdain
all the family wanted to do and all
Charlotte was interested in was to hear
an apology and a mere explanation as to
what happened she never wanted to take
antacou less away from her kids
and a message to the U.S government from
the younger generation is you're not our
friend this is not how allies treat one
another
this has turned into a massive
International dispute but we've I've
spent time with the family every day and
what they have to go through on a daily
basis is awful and unacceptable
but this is not an isolated incident
the U.S government are treating many
families like this around the world as
much they try and hide it
and I would just encourage you to to
watch this space is our me and my team
will focus on exposing them and fighting
them on every corner and uh thank you
very much yeah all said well said right
we're happy to take as many questions
for the parents as you like we've got a
bit of time so Lisa do you want to go
first you guys if you want to step
forward
step forward Sky News yeah how are you
feeling job done Promise complete
properly properly complete now you know
and tequilis has a criminal record for
the rest of their life
um that was something that you know they
never she never thought she'd see the US
government never thought that they'd see
and we've worked tirelessly and
relentlessly to make sure that she in
the end still had to do what you and I
would have had to have done so yeah
Harry we've done it and wicked wickets
we would we would have been happy with
anything we've never been invested in in
what the judge was going to hand down
for us it was just all about doing that
doing the right thing getting through
the UK justice system and done yeah
be much too little too late I think
isn't it job's done now yeah you have a
chance to do the right thing you do it
at the beginning you don't wait wait for
three years and put families Through
Torture and then try to do the right
thing when it's going to make you look
good it's up to them but if that you
know I've reached out in Olive Branch to
to them many many times it's never once
been accepted and you know look I I it's
up to the parents but my advice to them
is we move forward now she will have to
live with what she's done and the way
that they have treated this family for
the rest of their lives we have to live
without Harry but our conscience is
clear and uh yeah yeah
thanks Lisa um
Brokenness
you know everything I said in that
statement is yeah 100 true you know and
some you know you could never put into
words how bad things are
um but
you have to keep going you can't give up
you know we have to show Niall and the
other children that actually do you know
what
we can live our lives again somehow
we're still we've got to try and figure
out how we do that you know we've all
got therapy and everything in place and
we are
hoping that with with an awful lot of
help around us including our family and
friends
that we'll we'll get there we'll do it
you know and our family and friends have
been extremely affected as well you know
they're all quite a few family members
and friends who are pretty poorly too
after having watched everything in the
last three years and a bit you know it's
devastated many lives not just not just
us parents and the siblings so
it was hell reading it absolute hell I
knew I wasn't going to be able to do it
without
breaking
um but it had to be done had to be done
thank you
I I'm still in shock I think I'm still
processing but we've actually got to
this stage we've been fighting for for
the last three years so I don't know at
least if it's really sunk in yet they're
too early it's you know we
it's been such a baffle and such a
relentless
time that actually today is the day that
it's been decided you know the Judgment
has been passed and something's been
passed and we as a family of
fought off everything we can to get this
and I'm immensely proud of these guys
and the family
and uh thank you thank you thank you to
all of you for supporting us yeah in
this momentous day thank you
oh my goodness me I mean
she should have been there you know
we would have been
and I think it's despicable that she
didn't come over on the judge's orders
um yeah huge huge coward you know we we
had an option at the beginning of all of
this to take things laying down and have
Harry's life swept aside or we stand up
and fight and you face every hurdle that
we've had to jump over many many times
in the last three years three months
we weren't cowards we didn't back away
from the U.S government or the UK
government in the in in the beginning we
didn't back down you know because we
have values
maybe she doesn't
and the judge paid tribute to you as a
family I mean you've been through so
much going to the White House
it's gonna take us an awful long time to
sync everything in you know with with
the campaign work going along at the
pace that it has done
you don't get time in between to really
reflect on the fact you've just got back
from the states or you've just met who
was president Trump at the time you
don't get any times to reflect on one
interview to the next either because
it's on to the next one and it's on to
the next part or the next meeting or the
next Zoom or the next travel to London
or Manchester or whatever so I think
now's our time
to
rest
we're going to leave the next part of
our campaign and the capable hands of
rad and Isaac will be behind the 100
you'll probably see us pop up in many
places over the the coming months and
possibly even years to make sure that
this never happens to another family
ever again certainly in this country
um that was also our number one aim
alongside getting our Justice for Harry
um so yeah just watch this space you
know we're going to continue to work to
make sure that no one suffers like we
have
um
the U.S government again the same as her
despicable really you know how on Earth
can they treat who is meant to be one of
their closest allies in this way you
know absolutely disgusted I'm disgusted
[Music]
any other questions
[Music]
yeah it's going to take us a while you
know we're under No Illusion it's not
going to be next month you know we may
get it before the end of next year so
there's a lot of work to do that rad
will take care of let me answer that
Lisa if that's okay so yeah so the next
step now is this family have been
deprived of their inquest and an inquest
is to determine how how Harry came to
meet his death we still do not have any
details of what happened to him that
night unbelievably after all this time
so the next phase of this campaign will
will turn to that we don't know when
that will be but hopefully sometime next
year and it will be a very involved
inquest given that we now know that
Harry was not the first person to die
outside a United States Air Force Base
there have been thousands of people
killed or seriously injured over the
decades at the hands of American drivers
and it must stop so that will be a focus
of the inquest and then after that
you know look the way this family
retreated at the outset
which shocked me
and which is why I went up the road
there are lots of lessons to be learned
we will be having a parliamentary
inquiry into the whole
uh the whole Scandal really and I think
the foreign office have acknowledged
today for the first time that they've
learned lessons but we want to work with
them in Parliament to make sure that
should this happen to another family
again they don't have to go through what
this family have been through so these
parents are heroes they have to cope
without their without their son every
day
but they are thinking about the next
family down the road and they're
dedicating their lives
to to to that project which uh you know
I don't know how much comfort it gives
them but to go to bed at night and
thinking that they are leaving a legacy
for Harry and that his life did matter
um that will make other people safer and
these people are absolute heroes in my
view
s do you think they've learned enough
well
um in fact just last night I learned
that that James cleverly the foreign
secretary wants to meet up meet us and
and we are just waiting to to to get
that in in the diary look I think we'll
be having extensive discussions with the
with the with the foreign office
um and look I I it has to be open and
transparent have they learned the
lessons you know only time will tell I I
think I was involved in another case
um recently outside ariath Lake and
Heath where I where we work with the
foreign office and in that case they
didn't let the person responsible go and
she will stay and face our justice
system so if that's anything to go by
yeah it's it's looking positive
um and look that's all you can ever hope
in life people do make mistakes
governments make mistakes we don't
believe that anybody was intentionally
trying to harm harm us but you know we
have to do better next time
do you see a point I'm sure of this that
you could find it in your heart to meet
directly with Mississippi
I can't answer that today probably not
no not for me either
yeah I think that's a that's a difficult
question I I've always encouraged it in
the past to have what we call
restorative justice meetings are very
very powerful
when you have a fender in front of a
victim and they talk to each other
but that is usually done fairly early on
and it does allow the parties to explain
how they feel to each other maybe for
the offender to express some remorse
but you know as you know and I think
some of you were there
we were thrust into the Oval Office in
2019 with apparently Mrs sakulis in the
Next Room and had not been made aware
that that was the purpose of our visit
to the White House
and I called I I called and into the
meeting because you cannot meet the
person who's just killed your son a few
weeks earlier in the Oval Office with
the world's media there with President
Trump you know going for his you know
Glory moment I you know I thought it was
the most disgraceful thing in in the
whole campaign these people were you
know just a few weeks off from losing
Harry they were like rabbits in a
headlight I had dragged them to the
United States and
your poor Charlotte didn't even know
where she was she didn't know what the
Oval Office was and there was President
Trump
planning to Ambush us with Mrs seculis
in the Next Room so different
circumstances maybe we would have met
her if they had done it properly maybe
but not the way yeah listen I'm so
disappointed in the U.S government I
don't know what's going on in Washington
at the Department of Justice and the
state department their decision-making
matrices are seriously sub-optimal and
they need to have a think about how they
behave and as Isaac said you know they
want a war they've got a war and we are
not going to let British citizens suffer
at their hands anymore
okay any more questions
we done yeah thank you all so much for
coming thank you thank you
so we're just hearing there from Harry
Dunn's family after the conclusion to
the case against Ann circulus of course
has now been sentenced to suspended uh
eight-month sentence so won't in fact
serve time and of course Ann circulus
was not there in person but joined from
the US via video link we heard Harry
Dunn's mother Charlotte Charles say job
done she felt uh in terms of their
campaign in the last couple of years
saying that Ann sakulus now has a
criminal record for the rest of her life
and she said Harry uh we've done it in
that regard she said she wasn't
particularly concerned about the
sentence himself but much but much of
what they've been doing in the last few
years has been about doing the right uh
thing uh she continued to say that she
could never put into words how bad
things are but she needs to show Niall
that's her Harry's twin and her other
children that they have their lives to
live as it relates to answer coolest
physical absence in court today Harry
Dunn's mother said she should have been
there and described answer kulis as a
huge coward she said we weren't cowards
we didn't back down because we have
values maybe she uh doesn't and uh did
also say the U.S government has been
despicable she's disgusted by them and
says how can they treat one of their
closest allies this way we did also hear
from uh rad Seeger who's the family
spokesperson in relation to their views
on the U.S government saying that the
real enemy is not miss sakulus who made
a mistake but the U.S government instead
of doing the right thing they decided to
kick Harry's family in the stomach and
that they'd taken a cowardly approach
throughout so rad Seeger did also
comment on Mrs Justice Chima Grubb and
paid tribute to the job she had done and
let's listen back to uh the judge's uh
some of the key comments she made during
the sentencing
you were released from the court but
directed to attend in person for this
sentencing hearing
I directed you to attend and observed
that attendance in person would be
strong evidence of remorse for the
offense of causing the death of Harry
Dunn by your careless driving the
sentence is eight months imprisonment
suspended for 12 months
there will be no additional requirements
the sentence means that if in the next
12 months you commit any offense
whether or not it is of the same type
for which I'm sentencing you today you
would find yourself before the court
again
uh Sky's shiny mariki is at the old
bayley and uh clearly some scathing
comments towards certainly the US
government towards Ann sakulus from
Harry Dunn's mother but at the same time
she was in a position to be able to say
job done
yeah absolutely listening to the family
just outside Court there was a reminder
this is a diplomatic issue which has
obviously been deeply personal for them
and deeply hurtful you had those strong
work towards and circulus but when
questioned by my colleague Lisa Dowd
about how she was feeling she
essentially said she looked up and she
said Harry we've done it in her own
words she she felt like this part of the
process is now complete their Quest For
Justice and the principle the idea that
answer coolest has been sentenced in a
UK Court even if she appeared via video
link that is now complete and I sat in
and heard the proceedings over the
course of the afternoon and what was
most striking when we heard from from
Harry's model was just how difficult
life has been without him she gave a
witness impact statement in which she
discussed her life since then and she
said well she broke down in tears at
various points and she said that she
regretted not making it to hospital on
time wishing she had left earlier to
delay Harry leaving the house so she
wasn't on the road so he wasn't on the
road at the same time
then she detailed the impact it had on
his twin Nile who is struggling with his
mental health she said that this was a
void that their family will obviously
never be able to fill and on the
Diplomatic issues and on the
relationship with America and the fact
that answer kulas was not extradited you
heard those strong words outside of
court by the family spokesperson and he
said that he felt that the US is
overseeing the UK's longest running or
one of their longest running allies and
the fact that they did not do more to
ensure that antofulus appeared in UK
Court was a serious issue they then went
on to say that this Saga this story is
not complete and that they will continue
to push for justice and pursue pursue
matters further along the line
stay with us sir because we just want to
Pivot and get some footage in from Mark
James Matthews in the U.S who caught up
with answer kulis's lawyers outside of
their offices
what words do you have for Harry Don's
family today have a nice day
have you compounded their grief by
delaying Justice for three years
it's three years too long for this
family to wait for justice
foreign
why didn't you go to attend court in the
UK
you are not getting in this elevator
okay go ahead
you are not getting in this house if you
don't mind you're not getting in this
elevator
Mr coolers why why did the haridon
family have to wait for three years to
see you receive Justice today
[Music]
what words do you have for Harry Ron's
family
[Music]
that was in fact uh Miss Sakura's
herself accompanied by her lawyers as
opposed to just her her lawyers not
making any comment essentially to James
Matthews questions so let's go back to
Lisa Dowd at the old bayley who's joined
by some members of Harry Dunn's family
yeah I'm joined by um Harry's mum
Charlotte Charles and the family
spokesperson rad Sieger and actually rad
was just looking at that footage that
James Matthews has sent to us from the
United States then showing Mrs sakulas
who wasn't answering any questions over
Harry's case
um uh Charlotte I know you're on a phone
just now to a family member so you
didn't get to see it but um what are
your feelings towards Mrs sakulas given
that she didn't turn up to court today
and she only took part in proceedings
from Washington
cowardly you know
we could have backed down over three
years ago and taken the Cowardly route
of not fighting we didn't do that we
jumped over many many hurdles in the
last three and a bit years and here we
are today so yeah unfortunately there's
no other word for it cowardly
she was watching over video link from
the United States to a very emotional
Victim Impact statement that you read
out
at one point she apparently wiped away a
tear can you can you take us through
what you told the court what impact this
has had on your family
just how hard every day is
and the physical side effects as well as
the mental side effects
you know your body doesn't work the way
it used to your
my menstrual system
um You probably heard me talk about that
that's how it's had a massive effect on
on all of that you know we're we're on
antidepressants
prescribed diazepam
just to be able to function each day you
know the gaping hole that is left the
void
that nothing can fill because Harry's
not here
you know the amount of love and support
that we get and the fact that I've got
Niall and the other siblings
helps me keep going because you know
they're my life
but there's still a void there's still
you know Harry should be here we're
having to live without him
and the day-to-day physical and mental
impact that has had
is just beyond horrific you know you
you're tearful one minute you're angry
the next you're shaky you still I still
after three years get halfway through
doing the mundane shop and leave the
trolley and run to the car you know you
can't you sometimes can't control when
it's going to hit you and when it hits
you it hits you bad are you happy with
the sentence you received today
the sentence was never anything that I
was invested in what I'm really happy
with is that the job's done Justice in
the UK court has been done that's what I
promised my boy
and that's exactly what we've done so I
am good I am thrilled that it's all over
with we need some time to absorb
everything that's gone on we need to get
on with our therapy and we need a bit of
a rest over over the next few weeks
before
this man here starts embarking on the
next phase Mrs sakulas we heard in court
has said that not a day goes by without
her thinking about your son
what do you make of that
I think she should have said that an
awful long time ago you know instead of
leaving us to just think bearing in mind
we've never had any direct direct
contact from her at all
I think she should have been saying that
an awful long time ago you know we've
we've been left for over three years
just assuming as we've seen with your
guys help that she's just getting on
with her life you know
um pretty unfair really and she's saying
that she remains open to meeting with
you and the family
is that something you might consider
going forward not anymore
you know it was always on the cards to
begin with I I never say never but now
over three years and without us fighting
in our campaign for as long as we have
and as strong as we have we wouldn't be
here today you know she wouldn't have
come to us to offer
to
talk to us or go through the system you
know it's what we have fought for as a
team and as a family with the help of
rad and his family that's why we're here
so I think the the time for any contact
and any remorse is long gone and I think
I what particularly came across in court
today was the true horror of that
evening we heard detail about the crash
about Harry's words
um he said don't let me die to a witness
didn't he
didn't want to die he didn't want to die
he asked them to not let him die you
know I have to live with that every day
every moment of every day every waking
moment every
minute of the night that you're laying
there you know just him literally
begging not to let him die he wasn't
ready to go he shouldn't have gone you
know there's no way that that boy
should have been laying there for as
long as he was either
in that amount of pain being so scared
and there's still so much more I've got
to find out but yeah harrowing to listen
to
and how it went to know
and we heard from your victim impact
statement how it has haunted you that
you weren't able to get to the hospital
in time to see Harry yeah totally we
tried our best
you know we we went to pick Nile up
immediately we got the phone call from
Tim
he was Harry was just too injured you
know unfortunately by the time we got
there he got
so I couldn't comfort him at all I
couldn't let him know that I was there
you know so for me the next best thing
was to kiss that Bruce lip a bit and
just let him know that I'll Fight For
Justice you know that's the promise that
I made to him was that I promised I
would get him Justice and
that's what's kept me going that's been
my driver because I just couldn't get to
him in time to tell him I loved him
because you were told weren't you
um after Harry's death that you had a
tiny chance of getting any less than a
one percent chance of getting Justice
and that was I think you said from a
police representative I suppose they
hadn't reckoned on um coming up against
such a family no clearly not and I think
the police in this country have been so
used to
not being able to do anything about it
if you like because it's happened to so
many other families over many many many
years now you know a lot of American
Service men and women have been flown
home within 24-48 hours of
of an incident occurring
um
nobody's ever fought before they've not
had the
the ways and the means to to fight
before you know we've now got social
media
we had a rad as we say you know a friend
of 20 years that thankfully for us
wasn't you know he'd retired
had an awful lot of legal knowledge you
know so
we're doing that for all of those people
as well and all of those families
and we're going to continue we're going
to to continue to do that but when we
got told
in my kitchen that we had a less than
one percent chance of getting a
conviction there was an automatic no
we're not we're not having this we're
not taking that laying down
um we asked the police to put us
straight onto their press office and we
went from there so it was just never
going to be accepted and no one would
have reckoned on your determination
getting you
to the White House to speak to president
Trump to Lobby him to do something but
of course he didn't did he can you can
you give me your Reflections at that
time you find yourself in the Oval
Office with the president of the United
States asking for help yeah crazy I mean
you know Harry had only been gone a few
weeks I think well I definitely know
looking back I was still very numb the
rest of the family was still very numb
you're in you're on automatic pilot mode
you just
seem to float through the days just not
really knowing where where your feet are
touching the ground and nothing feels
real anyway
and when the opportunity was presented
to us by A rad to go and meet with him
we were like well we're here we've got
to give it a go you know why not you
know what have we got to lose we had
absolutely nothing left to lose we'd
lost everything that we could have lost
so it was just a no-brainer you know rad
wasn't Keen initially he was worried we
didn't we didn't get offered a UK
representative to be with us so we only
had our rad
um and it was just ridiculous you know
they tried separating us from rad
um I didn't know we were in the Oval
Office I'm not into politics I didn't
have a clue what it looked like didn't
know where we were
very scary very daunting looking back on
it and then to be told that she was in
the Next Room and
Yeah Bang Out of Order none of us had
any therapists with us nobody no UK
advisor you know neither did she as far
as we're aware she had no mediators or
therapists either so it was totally and
utterly the wrong thing to do and yeah
quite frankly just a bit of a a PR stunt
I think yeah I think your concern that
night was that this was just going to be
a photo op for president Trump and Mrs
sakulas and that you'd all be happy and
you'd move on with your lives yeah
completely and you know that became very
evident because instead of us showing
out being shown out to the South lawn
where all of you guys and other people
from the Press were we got promptly
shown out the back door
and given the way you were treated and
the way you have continued to be treated
by the United States government and at
times the British government
how do you feel towards those two into
institutions now
it's a difficult one I mean the US is
definitely like that they they are not
my favorite people and they're never
going to be I don't think the UK
really led a stone back down badly in
the beginning they're they're starting
to come good I think
but um yeah I think I need to reserve
judgment for now and a final word to you
rad
um this isn't the end completely is it
that you've got more things that you
want to happen now well look today is
the end of the the the criminal phase
and again you know the
the suggestion at the time was that this
family were never going to get Justice
and that was never going to happen so
today
is Victory Day
less than one percent chance to me meant
nah this is going to happen because
that's not how we how we live our lives
in this country we we expect Justice to
be done
and
we can we can close this off now and she
had a she's got a very serious sentence
and you know today is about thinking
about Harry and today is about thinking
about the parents and their heroes in my
view but you're absolutely right Lisa we
now move forward to the next phase of
our Campaign which again heroically the
the parents
want to leave a legacy for Harry which
is that this will never happen again and
that is a very complicated issue and
yeah that's where we're turning to now
thank you both for joining us live on
Sky News we really appreciate it thank
you
so there you see a lasting Legacy for
Harry
um no
um
the family are not wanting to meet with
Mrs sakulas they're wanting to move on
they want to have an inquest into his
desk so they find out the full facts of
what happened that night and they want a
parliamentary inquiry as well to go
through the circumstances of what
happened and to try to ensure that this
never happened to another family the
treatment both that they receive from
the British government at the start of
this but also the U.S government as well
to Mark Austin here now uh just what you
followed this so closely I just wanted
to ask you I mean clearly the conclusion
of a very long and painful battle for
the family and the mother that you have
just been speaking to there
yeah when I first spoke to Charlotte
Harry's mum about this what struck me is
that they didn't get wind that Mrs
sakulas had left the country until
Harry's funeral nobody told them nobody
kept them in the loop so until then they
felt like the case was relatively
straightforward they knew who was
involved she was cooperating with police
they felt like all the proceedings were
going on as they should and then out of
the blue they find out that the suspect
has left the country and they understand
that she might have some kind of
diplomatic role some kind of diplomatic
protection and of course they are thrown
into a totally new world that involves
American spies an American Military Base
the president of the United States of
America the the British government the
police and they're trying to process all
this so trying to deal with all this but
at the very heart of it for them was
getting Justice for their son who was
killed in a terrible crash and for that
after three years of fighting they
finally have some kind of Justice Mrs
sekulas has voluntarily Taken part in
this in these proceedings albeit
remotely via video link from Washington
but they do feel that they've brought it
to Justice albeit kicking and screaming
in a way and in spite of her showing her
remorse and they they don't want to hear
it it's too late for them they wish
she'd have just come back to the UK for
this sentencing sentencing but of course
she was never going to do them
okay Lisa thank you very much indeed
let's just uh remind you then of what's
happened in the past couple of hours job
done they were the words of Charlotte
Charles outside the Old Bailey after a
judge sentence a former U.S spy for
causing the death of her son Harry Dunn
ever since the 19 year old was killed
when he was knocked off his motorbike by
Anne sekulis in August 2019 his family
have campaigned to bring her to Justice
this afternoon Mrs sekulis received an
eight-month suspended sentence Harry's
mother said it was Despicable that Mrs
sekulis had chosen not to travel to the
UK to appear in court in person let's
hear what Mrs Justice Chima Grubb KC had
to say
I directed you to attend and observed
that attendance in person would be
strong evidence of remorse failure of a
defendant in a criminal trial to attend
in person when directed to do so without
reasonable cause is an offense contrary
to the bail Act
it has the potential to affect the
Court's ability to administer Justice by
damaging the confidence of victims
Witnesses and the public more generally
in the effectiveness of the court system
for the offense of causing the death of
Harry Dunn by your careless driving the
sentence is eight months imprisonment
suspended for 12 months
there will be no additional requirements
the sentence means that if in the next
12 months you commit any offense whether
or not it is of the same type for which
I'm sentencing you today you would find
yourself before the court again
well speaking outside Court Harry's
mother Charlotte said she had now
fulfilled her promise to him
job done Promise complete properly
properly complete now you know Anthony
has a criminal record for the rest of
her life that was something that you
know they never she never thought she'd
see the US government never thought that
they'd see
and we've worked tirelessly and
relentlessly to make sure that she in
the end still had to do what you and I
would have had to have done so yeah
Harry we've done it and wicked wicket
well answer kulis has refused to answer
questions as she left her lawyer's
office in the United States Skies James
Matthews caught up with her
what what words do you have for Harry
Don's family today
founded their grief by delaying Justice
for three years
it's three years too long for this
family to wait for justice
why didn't you go to attend court in the
UK
thank you
okay go ahead
if you don't mind you are not getting an
accelerator
Mr coolers why why did the haridon
family have to wait for three years to
see you receive Justice today
[Music]
what words do you have for Harry Ron's
family
[Music]
and school is there unwilling to answer
the questions of James Matthews she has
however issued a statement saying this I
want to again extend my sincerest
condolences to Harry Dunn's family and
friends apologies for that we will get
the statement up uh in just a moment my
tragic mistake she said led to the loss
of Harry and I live with this regret
every single day
there is not a day that goes by that
Harry isn't on my mind and I am deeply
sorry for the pain that I have caused
it's for this reason that I have been so
committed to a resolution to this case
since 2019.
I know there is nothing I can say to
change what has happened I only hope
that the truth and a resolution to this
case will bring a measure of comfort and
peace as always I remain willing to meet
and apologize to Harry's family directly
if that would support their healing
Harry was a young man with his whole
life ahead of him I cannot imagine the
loss and I too deeply grieve for Harry
and his family I am grateful that I
could express my profound remorse to the
court and to Harry's friends and family
uh August 27 2019 changed the lives of
so many and I pray for healing I kindly
ask the media for privacy thank you